los equipos de emergencia de la gironda
creían que la batalla contra los
incendios forestales había terminado
pero el fuego se reavivó el martes las
llamas que asolaron parte de la región a
finales de julio habían sido contenidas
pero desde hace tres semanas los
rescoldos siguen ardiendo bajo tierra un
giro en los acontecimientos que los
bomberos temían luz y el incendio durará
días semanas o incluso meses mientras no
haya lluvias intensas que puedan
extinguir la mayor parte del fuego por
lo que es probable que tengamos que
esperar a las lluvias de otoño para
extinguir una gran parte del incendio
los bomberos de aveyron tienen los
mismos temores el suelo sigue siendo
peligrosamente seco condiciones
perfectas para que las llamas se
reaviven más de 1.700 hectáreas han sido
destruidas en la región del sur desde el
lunes con más tierras amenazadas los
bomberos no corren riesgos
nuestra tarea es apagar las llamas
raspando los tocones de los árboles para
evitar que el fuego se reavive
es un trabajo meticuloso si es un
trabajo realmente meticuloso que durará
días este tipo de incendios se denominan
incendios de turba aunque las llamas en
la superficie se hayan extinguido
luego sigue quemando la vegetación en
descomposición y las raíces bajo tierra
los intentos de turba pueden extenderse
a lo largo de un centenar de metros
antes de volver a aparecer en la
superficie por ejemplo se puede ver el
humo debajo de ese árbol eso significa
que el fuego podría estar ardiendo por
todas partes bajo nuestros pies para
contener los nuevos focos los bomberos
utilizan espuma para añadir la tan
necesaria humedad al suelo pero este
método puede no ser suficiente para
salvar las miles de hectáreas de terreno
en riesgo en girón das